I'm Neil Gershenfeld I direct the Center
for bits and atoms i just finished
participating in the session on smarter
cities it's sort of unusual for me I'm a
physicist but lots of things we do seem
to end up in cities we talked about
three different linked themes about
technology changing cities one is
intelligent infrastructure smart grid
internet of things that are used very
commonly as terms but in fact almost
always are used exactly backwards the
hearty of the Internet is what it does
is defined by what we connect to it not
what you're connecting it to but most of
the smart systems have dumb devices with
smart central control that's very hard
to change so our first piece is using
the architecture of the Internet to push
the intelligence to the edges of the
network so for energy-efficient all
those purposes you can fix it with
individual devices not with large
central change second step that comes
from that is we do a lot of us work on
machines that make machines technology
to create technology in cities what it's
leading to is a new notion of
self-sufficiency I mentioned an example
of a team now running the city of
Barcelona focusing on instead of buying
products from far away using these
emerging fabrication technologies so the
city in the city produces what it uses
so that skills and dobson are local
instead of fifty percent unemployment
buying products from far away and then
those two themes meet in a very
interesting way in creating
infrastructure for things like
communication large-scale city
infrastructure instead of those being
billion dollar investments to fund and
then amortize the technology that makes
it easier to talk about create
technology makes it easier to extend the
infrastructure of cities in these smart
ways getting their increasingly is
limited not by the technology but by
things like standards and by accounting
for life cycle costs and so that's where
we ended with some of the policy
implications